What creatures will you meet when you go
see the new movie Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves
oh that's not good
will there be an album
what is that again the mashup that
somehow tears all of the terror with
none of the cute from owls and bears
we're mimics monsters that composes
anything
will there be a gelatinous cube that
disarms its victims how about a
displacer beast a predator with
tentacles and cloaking abilities and
well isn't that more than enough
oh an intellect Devourer a giant brain
that consumes other brains like some
kind of awful brain cannibal the higher
the intelligence of the prey the more
likely they are to strike
oh that's a little hurtful or even
fember shot the red dragon who looks
like he ate all the other dragons as
appetizers
you'll just have to go see Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves to find out
foreign
once the dead man is revived we can ask
him five questions at which point he
will die again never to be re-revived
were you killed in the battle of the
every horse yes four more questions
right yes no no that wasn't for you did
that count as a question yes
damn it
only answer when I talk to you okay yes
why did you say Okay at the end of that
I didn't
fantastic where's the shovel